grafton ladies and gentlemen welcome to
designing for inclusivity
safeguarding culture and heritage my
name is jericho from design singapore
council and i will be your event
mcm moderator for today this session
is brought to you by design singapore
council the national agency for design
in singapore
supported by the national heritage board
the custodian of singapore's heritage
it is also supported by the national
design center and in august september
the center will be exploring events with
a thematic focus on singapore
our home this webinar is part of a
series of engagement and sharing
sessions
under the good design research
initiative which aims to help designers
and design enterprises in singapore find
a unique value proposition
in designing for impact through research
experimentation
or collaborating for network of
knowledge partners
information on a good design research
initiative will be shared with you
during the course of this session
we are honored to have the national
heritage board with us today
and various distinguished speakers who
will be contributing today's session
we hope to bring you on an inspiring
journey exploring how each of us
can contribute and play a part to embody
and retain our local heritage
before we proceed i would like to
highlight a few housekeeping rules
should you encounter any technical
issues please reach out to our crew
through the zoom chat function we ask
for your patience and understanding
should conditions be less than perfect
during this webinar your audio will be
on mute however your questions are
welcome
at any point in time just direct them to
us
under the zoom q and a function when
posting a question
please state your name and company and
if you have a specific speaker
whom you'd like to respond to your
question finally please be informed that
this session will be recorded
now please allow me to introduce the
speakers
and this afternoon's program
starting off my clique me from the
design singapore council
will be joining us to share an overview
of the good design research initiative
next we have mr joe kurtziang director
of the heritage
research and assessment division at the
national heritage board
mr yo currently leads the research
documentation
and commemoration of singapore's
tangible and intangible cultural
heritage
this includes the development of a
master plan that outlines the strategy
for singapore's heritage sector
following which we have mr raymond huang
fashion and boutique director of ruma
kimchi
who will be speaking on a narnya kambaya
promoting and safeguarding the timeless
beauty
mr wong is a third generation chinese
piranha khan and today he is one of the
last few kabaya makers in singapore
mr wong also lectures part-time at
lasalle college of the arts
last but not least we have mrs tan from
taogwong pottery jungle
her presentation topic will be on
keeping the fire alive
alongside her husband and niece mrs time
manages taekwon
a family business that owns and operates
one of the two last remaining dragon
cleans in singapore
in addition taekwon hosts a wide range
of outreach programs
and community initiatives that aims to
educate the public on the wood firing
pottery process
in doing so they have transformed into a
hub for a community of local clay
artists
taught was also recently awarded the
inaugural stewards of singapore
intangible cultural heritage
award by the national heritage board
without further ado
i will now hand you over to huemei who
will be giving you a great introduction
to the good design research initiative
who may please thank you jericho for the
quick introduction
and thank you all for taking the time to
join us today
so i'm not sure how many of you may have
heard of the good design research
initiative before
and so i would like to take this
opportunity to share with you
a little bit more on the background of
this initiative
so first i'll be sharing on why good
design research is important and then
secondly
on the key elements of the initiative
so its importance in today's context was
very apparent when we conducted our
groundwork
in close consultation with designers and
design enterprises
we interviewed over 40 of them with most
of them recognizing that designing for
impact which is also what most will
recognize as good design
that will help them shape their unique
value proposition
and stand out in the global marketplace
and then on the demand side there has
always been a recognition of the role
that design can play
in mitigating the world's complex issues
for example sustainability as well as
inclusivity and diversity
the role that design can play is
especially apparent in this
covet pandemic and the design innovation
that we need right now
goes beyond simply improving their user
experiences for retail and
f b but also requires deep research
so clearly there is a need for deep
research that is fundamental
to good design however good design
research requires two key elements
firstly it requires significant
investment and secondly a strong network
that is not always possible with smaller
design firms
and therefore our good design research
initiative
the council plans to bridge these two
resource gaps
so firstly the good design research
initiative aims to help
build a strong network and ecosystem to
foster
multi-disciplinary collaborations that
are necessary for design impact projects
we are hoping to achieve these through
the webinar
as well as the subsequent sharing and
engagement
sessions the second part of the good
design research initiative
aims to support exploratory projects
through open calls
and this support includes sponsorship
publicity support
as well as mentorship so through
this through two-pronged approach the
good design research initiative
encourages designers to develop their
unique value proposition
in particular we are looking at projects
that seeks to support
sorry in particular we are looking at
projects
that focuses on deep explorations and
research in today's
three key tricks you have your identity
and culture
systems and processes and new
technologies
we are also focusing on research
projects with a focus on design impact
so i hope this brief overview gives you
a rough idea of what the good design
research initiative is all about
and if you would like to find out more
information please scan the qr code on
the bottom right of the slide
and now i'll pass the time back to
jericho
thank you humi you will now invite mr
yokshan from the national heritage board
who will be sharing with you more about
what exactly is intangible cultural
heritage
and overview of the traditional
craftsmanship landscape in singapore
mr yo please thank you jericho
and thank you to design singapore for
inviting me to
share today's presentation my
presentation is
on the intangible cultural heritage and
traditional craftsmanship in singapore
so a bit about nhb where i work in we
are statutory board under the ministry
of
culture community and youth and our
mission is to preserve and celebrate
the heritage of our diverse communities
and we do this through the promotion and
safeguarding of different forms of
heritage
and heritage will include museum
artifacts
historic buildings as well as intangible
cultural heritage
so what is this tangible and tangible
cultural heritage that i
just mentioned well tangible is really
talking about the physical aspects you
know the artifacts
could be the historic buildings it could
even be the
documents that tell our history on the
other hand we have intangible cultural
heritage
so these are the practices the knowledge
the craft skills they are handed down
from generation to generation
and evolves over time as people
innovate and change their practices so
this evolution is why we also call these
forms of heritage
as living heritage so in as part of
nhb's work we tried to create a
what we call an inventory of intangible
cultural heritage
and this can be for our website as shown
here and intangible cultural heritage
can take many forms that could be
festivals
they could be it could be our
traditional performing arts
craft skills and also our food heritage
that we enjoy
just some examples of the different ichs
that can be found in singapore
many of you will be familiar with the
festivals such as chinese new year
bali there are also
more other religious festivals they are
less known for example the night april
gods festival
uh various forms for traditional arts
like indian dance
or art forms like rangoli
malay medicine and also traditional
theater such as
community crafts traditional craft
skills is a major part of our
cultural heritage and these are sort of
the hand skills the artisan
knowledge that is passed down from one
generation to the next
uh they are often a source of
liabilities for our practitioners
because
it's part of their business and it's
also a reflection of the
culture and creativity of the
communities and individuals
so the pictures here show madame lee for
example repairing the rakhtan furniture
and mr wong who
handmade this fuchsia traditional
lanterns
and there are many more that traditional
crafts that can still be found in
singapore like the making of joysticks
making of traditional indian gold
jewelry
chong som dairying kabani making and
later on we also have
mrs khan and raymond sharing on their
respective craft skills
um just some more examples to share and
we should
go into that a little bit more for
example we have
kertupat weaving here in the slides
it's a form of traditional crafts
because it's really associated with the
malay community in singapore
uh and it's of course associated with
the food
that um the malay counterparts
enjoy doing hariraya only food but also
there are
pouches that are weaved into colorful
ribbons as part of the decorations
during the festive periods and it's a
kind of
family activity where the children the
younger generation learn from their
elders on how to make a navy
just now i mentioned mr wong who makes
traditional chinese lanterns
so these are the traditional lanterns
they are handmade and
hung outside traditionally outside homes
temples and kind associations
he has tried to innovate i think
traditional
craftsman should can also involve
innovation for example he uses tin
aluminum rods
to produce his traditional chinese
lanterns and he also uses different dyes
to show some some of the more
traditional
auspicious characters but also painting
the lanterns with more contemporary
motifs such as orchids
and even the sg50 we said celebrated it
a couple of years ago uh another example
is a chinese cyborg carving
so contemporary style bots which are
manufactured of course is an evolution
and traditionally these cyborgs are
carved by hand
so to that is some kind of loss with um
replacement of machines and i think this
practitioner mr yong does feel that way
that you know a
sideboard that's made by machine is not
as beautiful and lacks
texture and personality so when we are
trying to modernize
our traditional crafts i think it's also
important that we see how this
modernization and
contemporary design can value add to the
process
while retaining some of the essential
essence and values
that our traditional crafts contain
there are many challenges facing
traditional crafts in singapore
one is the economic sustainability of
the trades
um there is kind of a general lack of
the value that such
crafts can bring to the broader economy
or even the spotlight on the livelihoods
or practitioners
of course our practitioners also face
stiff competition especially
competition with cheaper mass-produced
imports
so this makes the economic
sustainability quite challenging
the next point i would like to make is
how do we make sure that the knowledge
continues on
passing down from generation to
generation just like how
our past forefathers pass down our
traditional knowledge to the current
generation
one challenge that we often hear is the
lack of skill
successors who are keen to take on
the craft and i think it's also linked
to this
important point about how do we keep
things relevant
for the younger generations it can be
quite challenging to attract our younger
generation
to be part of this traditional craftsman
industry given um you know typical
perceptions could
range from such crowds being very
laborious unprofitable or some may even
deem it as lacking in prestige
on our part we try to safeguard and
promote intangible cultural heritage
through a war that we give out give out
given out this year it's titled the
stewards of intangible cultural heritage
award
and with it comes a grant is our attempt
to try to recognize and support our
cultural heritage practitioners who have
made significant contributions
and for their passion in trying to
sustain and transmit their
intangible cultural heritage so these
are just pictures of taoguang poetry
jungle
i'll leave mrs tan later on in the
presentation to share more about her
crafts but i think beyond the award i
think
my colleagues and i we are looking at um
other ways on how do we safeguard our
heritage
um can our traditional practices carry
on
in today's digital world and how can
traditional
craftsmanship and bonded modernity come
together
and then are they mutually exclusive or
can there be a happy marriage of
heritage and design so my next few
slides will touch on some examples where
traditional craftsmen have tried to work
together with
designers to come up with more
innovative
products and reimagining our traditional
crafts
here's a local example by say tianhin
which is a 124 year old taoist effigy
making shop
located in chinatown so the shop
launched
international design competition
challenging designers to reimagine the
wooden statue of the monkey god
and how it can be reimagined to suit a
wider audience
and whether it can be recreated into not
just a
religious artifact but possibly a work
of art
that while maintaining the use of the
traditional techniques
they are used to make them in 2019
there was also a project by the art link
to introduce traditional
japanese craft skills to new audiences
so under this project there were 12
craft makers
from japan they were paired up with
singapore designers to co-create a
series of
furniture and lifestyle products while
using the traditional japanese
craftsmanship
in hong kong they have also tried to do
something similar
there is a non-profit organization in
hong kong called crafts on pew
and they'll try to solve match made
traditional
craftsmen with artists through an
artisan residence program
and this is coupled with exhibition
titled crafts interwoven
past and present so under this program
in hong kong
what they've done is to try to pair
contemporary artists
with local traditional craftsmanship to
explore how
our traditional crafts can be
reinterpreted into artistic
rendering so so here are some examples
one here's a picture of a console table
that's handmade
using bamboo without any glue or nails
and this design is actually inspired
by the making of the traditional chinese
handcrafted bird cages
such bird cages used to be a common
sight in hong kong
tea houses of the past still on the hong
kong initiative
is here's an example in the picture of a
chandelier
and it's actually designed and made
using a traditional
bamboo steamer which many of you will be
familiar when
if you are eating dim sum so what they
did is to get the traditional craftsmen
to work on a bamboo to craft it
so the bamboo pieces are still made
steam softened calf
using a traditional techniques but of
course here they're not they're using it
to make a
light piece so in india there's also
similar examples that can be found
here's a collaboration that we found
involving a philanthropy
foundation be open together with the
fashion design council of india
and various indian lifestyle brands
together working together with
traditional craftsmen
so they try to co-create traditional
crafts
and to exhibit as well as so sell off
the products
so that the this also provides a form of
likelihood
both for the designers as well as the
traditional craftsmen who are involved
in the process
so here are some examples here here's
one
from a lighting installation that's
inspired by the local
traditional glass blowers from northern
india so the glass blowers
created this piece in the shape of a
peacock which also
closely associated with the india's
heritage
so the feathers here for example are
made using 48
glass stems created by the traditional
glass flowers
here's a collaboration between uh
designers and the stone cutters from
tavernado
so the stone cutters were brought in to
produce flooring strips
from granite as well as table surfaces
for the installation
so all these are handmade by the stone
masons
using their place grinding
stones i've just shared a few examples
of
you know the marriage of design with
traditional crowds but i think we also
have to be
mindful of there could be some potential
sensitivities
uh between getting inspiration
but um on a more negative side it could
be accused of being a cultural
appropriation
concept that is highly uh sensitive
especially in western countries
so here are the pictures show some
examples the picture on the left is one
from a toronto gallery
where artists mentioned that she was
inspired by
the indigenous art forms and from there
she
created art that is so-called based and
inspired by this indigenous art
but i think it raises concern from the
indigenous people there
and it was forced to cancel the art show
because of it
and picture on the left is one of issue
that is sometimes seen in the fashion
scene so here's an example where
london-based fashion label had to
apologize to the canadian descendants
for appropriating a design that was used
in a traditional
outfit and they had adapted it to a
fashion runway design here
so i think it's important that we when
we are working with traditional
craftsmen
we also have to find a way of how do we
give the dual recognition and
respect for the traditional crafts and
traditional
heritage that is associated with
coming back to singapore i think it's
we're hoping to
see whether heritage can play an
important role in design
we do see more interest in heritage
especially in the last few years
and potentially this could give rise to
perhaps more interest in handmade
artisanal products that are inspired by
heritage
we do see a growing demand in the market
in singapore as well as abroad
for designs that embody distinct
cultural
identities and characteristics and we
also see this as a way to
bring about innovation and uh to our
traditional crafts in a meaningful way
how do we do it in a balanced way that
is while
you come with new designs but at the
same time respect
respecting the traditions and the
culture of the people
uh and of course um could there be
designs that are inspired
are inspired by our singapore cultural
heritage i think that's also
quite meaningful as we find ways to
preserve and safeguard our heritage
so at nhb i think what we're trying to
do is to run a small pilot
we're hoping to raise a public awareness
and appreciation for our local craftsmen
one idea that we had was to pair just
like the
international examples we i presented
could we pair traditional craft
practitioners together with our
designers
to for for partnership this could help
our traditional crowds people who are
willing to innovate but perhaps
they don't know how to or don't have the
networks to do so
and pairing them up with designers who
are willing to
to learn a bit about traditional crafts
and to find
ways to incorporate it into newer
designs so this is still a
very much a preliminary idea but if you
have any any thoughts
do feel free to contact my colleagues
who i mentioned in this
slide here so in conclusion
uh as my presentation has highlighted
there are still many traditional crafts
that remain in singapore
and they are form an important part of
our cultural and living heritage
of course there is undeniably some
challenge in ensuring that they
continue to pass on to the next
generation and we want to see
how as we have observed in other
countries how
perhaps some experimentation some
modernizing
and some more contemporary tips on
traditional crafts
could help us to find a way to evolve
and keep our cultural heritage alive
perhaps through new designs
they are also unique and stand out from
the good standardized or industrial
products that we often see on the market
and
lastly i also mentioned that it's while
we
want to modernize our experiment i think
it's also important that we not forget
the cultural values
associated with the crafts and the
passion and dedication of our
practitioners as well
and with that thank you very much and
this ends my presentation
thank you mr you for bringing us to the
insightful presentation
now if there are any questions that you
might have about the presentation
please send them via the zoom q and a
module
and we will bring them up for discussion
later on during the q a
now let's take half a minute here to
hear from you
about your opinions on cultural heritage
a poll should now appear on your screens
with the question should cultural
heritage be
allowed to vanish on its own over time
let us know what you think
okay we will now end the poll well i'm
very glad to see that 94
of you think that cultural heritage
should not be allowed to vanish over
time
so i think across the next two
presentations our practitioners will be
sharing with us on what they have
done to safeguard the transmission of
their craft and to ensure that it can be
carried on for generations to come
next up we have mr raymond wong from
muma kimchi who will be sharing with us
more about the narnia kabaya mr wong
please
hi i'm raymond wong here and
i'm the owner of roma kimchi and i i
would like to thank uh designs
singapore and nhp for giving this
valuable chance
to actually do this session with you all
so i'll be going to the next slide
please
uh next please thank you
so um this is a statement by carl sagan
many years back when i first saw this
statement
it inspires me a lot when it comes to
designing my work
and i always feel that there's a need to
know and understand
the historical part of our culture and
understand how can we innovate and
create something out of it
for our present and our future and by
understanding the
historical part of it it also protects
ourselves from
cultural appropriation because many are
times when people are accused of being
appropriating other people's culture it
always happens the case whereby
they do not understand the cultural
significance about it
and they try to adulterate it to the
point that
it is not respectable to the other
communities
so understanding the history and it's
really very important to
when i do my own work so we'll go on to
the next slide
so what is pranagan culture pranayama
culture actually best
fascinates me a lot because it's a
lifestyle culture born from
acculturation
within the major cities in southeast
asia and back then most of the women
folk around
malay archipelago and indonesia would
wear this conservative dress code
as it was a popular
fashion back then in that era and this
and to the next side please
and as i mentioned the saran kobaya
is actually a folk fashion and this folk
fashion comprises
three main parts which is basically the
embroidered top which we know as the non
kabaya
the batik sarong the kronsang and the
beaded shoes
so this is considered a slow fashion
because every part of the ensemble
it takes time to complete for instance
for the bearded shoes itself
like a pair of beaded slipper like this
um
done with the old check beads no one can
imagine that it requires at least about
10 000 beats
and it can take our attentions about six
to eight weeks to complete
so such is a very good example of
what is slow fashion all about okay next
so um in 2004 when i first started out
doing my business
it's a niche business so it can be quite
difficult and there were quite a number
of
um issues that i faced first would be
the lack of social environment
uh we noticed that a lot of young people
find no relevance
of the traditional folk fashion um to
their lifestyle they don't feel a sense
of belonging and pride wearing their
clothes
and they always see it as an old costume
and it's only worn by the older
generation
or they will always feel right in the
kabaya because they are afraid of people
speaking baba
toa to them so the second one would be
the lack of understanding and
appreciation of the folk fashion
so a lot of young generations do not
understand how hard business owners
like ourselves are trying to maintain
our consume
our customer base here especially in
times like today
we actually face a lot of competition
from past fashion
uh why is that so because fast fashion
produce quotes really very fast
and the pricing are always mostly quite
affordable
so a lot of young people today they
actually find there's no need for
customization
and then and when it comes to
practicality part they actually find
that
oh i only read the combine for only
formal occasions and that's it maybe
once in my whole lifetime
it's not like in the past um the pre the
older communities would actually wear it
as a daily wear
and lastly evolution of the folk fashion
um when it comes to looking at the
translation into a
contemporary form and how we appeal to
the young people
we i always try to challenge myself that
how are we going to make the craft
relevant and functionable to us again
and how can we adapt new technology to
make this folk fashion
easier to produce and um lastly is
should the cultural folk fashion evolve
into something new
which young people may appreciate better
okay we'll go on to the next slide
so um one of the solutions is
the social environment we need to have a
very strong social environment that
allows people to appreciate our culture
better
so from these uh examples over here you
see in the present
presentation we are actually very
fortunate because since i returned from
melbourne in 2004 to today
we noticed that there's various agencies
whether government or non-government
they actually come forward
and try to create a social environment
that allows our
culture and other cultures to be noticed
and appreciated
especially when um especially nhb
since the opening of the chronicle
museum in 2006
we noticed that there are more pranaykan
festivals heritage trails and programs
coming up
and this actually educates and instills
interest
in the community at large to this
to rediscover this intangible heritage
and if you look at the next slide you'll
see that in 2008
uh we have these two posters of the
little nunya drama
so this drama was actually first shown
in two years and it sparked a lot of
interest
locally and overseas back then
and and a lot of young singaporeans
start to
feel that they want the culture to be
part of themselves
so you will start to hear things like oh
i'm one one third paragraph and i'm one
sixteenth rana gun
and i want to wear the kabaya again and
more people wants to have combined team
parties
whether it's wedding or dinner functions
and you notice that media like this
actually created
a very good synergy with the evidence
which has been done previously to create
a living social environment
so this year if you look at our china
site
in 2020 they actually had the china
version of the little known year
and it seems to created a terrorist in
china
but um because of kovit now we see very
little chances that they will actually
come and appreciate the culture better
in singapore
but we actually do see a lot of local
based chinese
people coming to our shop to get a set
of a buyer or even random for photo
shoots
and start sharing them on qq and wechat
accounts
so it is such interest that would allow
our culture to
uh perpetuate for a long longer period
yeah
and next so um when it comes to
understanding and appreciating the folk
fashion
uh we need to create a need among our
local people that the folk fashion
actually provides them a sense of
belonging and pride
and such costumes are actually taking a
lot of time and affection to produce so
it is very desirable to own them
and lastly these items if
are often more meaningful and they are
passed down as
hello and memory
so um so how do we go about doing that
in our next slide you'll see that um
nowadays we notice more and more people
are using kabaya
as a folk fashion because it's an
evergreen costume
you can never go wrong wearing a
traditional kebaya
uh that represents your country and
the nunia kabaya itself it represented
singapore's multiculturalism really very
well
so you'll also see that uh it's often
used
in um overseas um events too
and in the next slide today
when it comes to um translating into a
contemporary form we try to make the
kabaya appealing to the young people
because um by doing that we always
try to uh meet our customers talk to
them and see what are their
expectations and requirements whether
they want to wear the kabaya for a
festive location or their weddings or
rank abroad
whether they need it to be very grand
with crystal zone on top
so these are the things that we always
we need to be always be
sensitive to our clientele's um
requirements
so for example one of the requirements
that we noticed for a lot of young
people
is that they find that kabaya needs to
be very comfortable
and provide them ease of movement so
that's why in this uh series of photos
here
notice that um the essence of the kabaya
is actually the silhouette
so no matter how i try to modify the
cabinet i
ensure the silhouette is still there so
when it comes to ease of movement
you notice that i've been experimenting
on modern cuts
mermaid scales which allows better
movement
for our younger generation customers and
likewise we also have some customers who
often say hey kabay is very warm to wear
in singapore weather
and i like to show off my shoulders like
like whenever i wear evening gown
so you notice that even quarter cut
versions of money cabinet if you see
right at the bottom over there
you'll notice that it is one of a
popular design which our customers like
when they come to customize in our shop
in our next slide so
when it comes to um designing decor
buyers
i always like to explore various other
fabrics other than the voice and the
organdy
that most people would relate to buyers
with
so i always try to encourage and uh
give new looks to the buyers to appeal
them so that they can actually wear the
combine not just with the sarong but
also with their modern ware
so for instance lace is a popular
material for many designers locally and
abroad so in the center of the
presentation you would
see that um there is a beautiful lace
and thick
buyer that i've taken this photo from
the pranaka museum
you will notice that back then the
kabaya is already very
elegant because it's not too colorful
and surprisingly with that european
look in the midst of designs you can see
the pranagan chinese are already using
lace techniques to do dragon oriental
motifs onto the kabaya
so we noticed that um um
young people today they are actually
quite into
not so colorful but monotone cabarets so
you notice that on the
picture on the right side you uh this
right here she's actually wearing
a lace style kabaya which we have
inspired and did for her
and after the wedding this combine can
also be used like a bolero over your
your modern wear and you can still wear
it not just for your wedding itself
and of course um to make the lace kobaya
more interesting
i actually often go up to wgsn which
which is now known as
essential it is actually um
um a website that actually does fashion
forecasts on the
next color scheme seasons so often the
case i will always
try to forecast what are the colors that
is available in the market
and what the colors that is foreseen by
wgsn
and i'll make them into lace cabinets so
for instance
koncheng man she's actually wearing a
lace-style kabaya
and most of the embroideries are mostly
in lilac and it was the colored
in fashion back then in that year and
and i actually match it with a dark
purple song skirt
so this appeals to clients who are not
into very colorful or overly floral
clothes
but they are into modern but matching
clothes
so these are the things that we have to
learn to be sensitive to our clientele's
needs
next
so in lasalle i teach kabaya
embroidery to my students and we try to
encourage them
that when we do embroidery we do not
just restrict them onto
the buyers often we try to encourage
them to
apply the techniques learned onto their
clothes like the chongsam
or their block card clothes and this
would actually
make their collection exclusive so for
instance
this is the basic chongsam but we
actually add embroideries onto it that
it looks like a tattoo at the back of
the
costume over here and next
um now uh when it comes to
um understanding the current market
we have to always adapt ourselves to
what is going on
around the world whether it and today i
actually placed quite much emphasis on
the technology
sustainable fashion and collaboration
with
people who could actually help to
promote the culture
so in terms of our technology in the
next slide
you would see that in the past the buyer
is actually done using the travel sewing
machine which you see
this lady in black and white she's
actually using the single sewing machine
to coordinate with her legs and hands to
apply the embroideries
onto the buyer but nowadays
with technology you can actually use
very good quality electric sewing
machines
and nowadays with the sewing machines
they have speed controls that allow us
to control the speed of the sewing
machine to allow
students to learn the art of carbine
embroidery faster
and at the same time with other
functions like
the light bulbs to improve clarity
and we also have things like safety
mechanisms that
if um if the sewing machine is not
properly engaged
the machine will not move but alert the
user that there is
a safety bridge which is very important
because with
in our today's work we try to minimize
accidents unnecessary accidents and
lastly we can see that we have this
machine over here which is
a computerized embroidery machine this
is something that
um my team are actually trying to
experiment
and see how can we use this in our
current
cabinet making though we are still in
the teething stage
but difficulties that we face would be
things like
to design an embroidery it can take a
long time you really need experience on
using the software
the machine itself is not difficult to
use but it is the designing of the
software
and we notice that there are very
limited avenues
for people like ourselves or even my
students
to actually explore or get people who
have the knowledge to actually teach
them on this area of machine and
embroidery using the computer and next
so for better technology and giving our
customers a
better experience we try to use apps
like photoshop
or procreate to aid us in the drawing
and designing effectively
for example for instance in this uh
slides here you can see
we are using our color wheel and we try
to calibrate
to the textile color as close as
possible and then we try to
apply our design onto the cloth and draw
our designs
and match the track colors based on what
we have
are intended for this design and this
would actually allow us to better
appreciate
whether the design is beautiful and it
also manages the customer's
expectations better next
so sustainable fashion is something that
currently i'm looking into because
nowadays there are many young people
they are into reducing pollution and
going green
as part of their initiative
so to appeal to younger generation
uh and being a environmentally
responsible
business going sustainable is actually
one of the revenues
that we are actually going now so in our
next slide
i'm going to show you a piece of butter
which is a 2.5 meter batik
and you can see that usually a piece of
butter we can actually make them
into a piece of short sleeve buttock
shade like you see on your
extreme left and often the case when a
customer wants to do
a long sleeve shirt we'll require two
pieces of a similar fabric
and often the case is not easy to find
two similar pieces
and even if we do what do we do with a
balanced cloth so
often the case will try to do them into
sustainable fashion like
we try to match them with our matching
colored fabrics
and uh try to add textures onto the
buttock so that you
you personalize the shirt and this [ __ ]
will be a once off
um design which we do usually can't
replicate
anymore next
and a while ago we mentioned about um
the buttock cloth if you want to do a
long sleeve shirt
you'll require at least two meters or
two pieces of 2.5 meter clock
and often the case it is really very
difficult
so what happens is we actually work very
closely with our artisans
artisans whereby um we actually show
them
that um buttocks can be drawn in a way
like you seen over here
you can see the dragon designs instead
of drawing
eight panels of floral designs to make a
long sleeve shirt
by cutting up the segments and drawing
our specific designs up there
we actually mainly do only two main
panels of designs
so this actually would reduce work and
time spent on making the cloth
and this club itself can be enough to
make from small size to double xl
whereas if we use two pieces of 2.5
meter cloth
because of the matching fabric we might
end up only doing a maximum up to about
xl nothing more than that because
usually cutting off or when you try to
match the print it can take up quite a
lot of cloth
and lastly um we have a lot of young
people
they are inheriting a lot of old
buttocks from
their grandparents or friends and often
this cloth our bucket chillis which is a
hand-drawn cloth
and to cut the cloth is really such a
waste so nowadays as part of our
sustainable efforts we
are into making sauron cloth by not
cutting them into
actual skirts but stitching them up by
hand and make them into a tight skirt
so being a tight skirt will be easier
for modern young girls to wear because
a lot of young people do not know how to
fold the surround skirt so this would be
a perfect
solution for many young people at the
same time and next
and i mentioned a while ago that cobias
are often passed down as an aloe item
what happens if your
buyer has fabric has spoiled over the
years and we know that tobias can take
six to eight weeks to complete so
usually the case is that
i would encourage young customers that
hey bring down your tobias
we can try to use our buyer techniques
and applique your kebaya
embroideries onto a new cabinet to
salvage it
and this is how we actually do it in the
presentation slides
we cut out the fabric lay nicely into
the cloth
and then we complete them into a cabinet
and look as good as new over here
next and nowadays
when it comes as i mentioned a while ago
that it takes six to eight weeks to
complete the cabaret
we would also sometimes pre-embroider
our cloth
into a 2.5 meter cloth like what we see
over here
with the two laptops in front the
embroideries at the back
and two and smaller embroideries for the
sleeves this would actually
reduce our opportunity cost and waiting
time for customers
who are waiting for the clothes to be
customized the opportunity cost is
usually the situation whereby
by the time we complete a costume the
customer's expectation of the clothes is
not what they
expect it's usually in terms of the
color matching
especially so by making the clothes with
this cloth
uh it makes things easier for us and
people often say
hey there's a wastage of cloth around
the fabric after we have making it
often we we would do them into our
pocket squares
by embroidering only the corner tip or
whenever we cut out our cloth
the balance embroideries will just cut
out and applicate them onto
pouches or make them into small little
sustainable items
like this happen over here so we do not
try to
waste every part of the fabric and next
in this slide in times of covet um
business for us is also rather brief and
everybody is actually experiencing this
same
problem too so it is also a time that we
actually try to reorganize and re
restructure ourselves because um during
the period
uh we decided to do buttock mass and
there was a demand for reusable mass
back then
so just happened so that we were
upcycling all our buttock remnants
and this cloth can be recycled or
upcycled into mass
and surprisingly as the time goes
we start to have more customized orders
whereby people say that hey i want
um our mask with beadwork our mask that
matches with our costumes
and this becomes a market opportunity
that
our our cultural arts is not just
limited to the costume
it can be extended far beyond into
lifestyle items
and in our next slide um when it comes
to collaborations
with designers and events companies this
is a platform that as
um mentioned earlier by the previous
stickers
we lack such platform and this platform
actually allows us to have a greater
exposure
to to promote our art
further so for example um you can see on
your top
right hand corner you can see uh john
lee he's wearing
a shirt that frederick lee has made and
designed for him
and the embroideries are actually are
designed and done by us
so this goes to show that collaboration
can be done to create
something new and different especially
the next one whereby collaborated with a
young designer
aaron choi from the square bespoke
where we actually try to combine a
sustainable fashion of balanced buttock
cloth
to make a men's jacket to make it
something different and unique
and of course when it comes to events uh
we try to
um collaborate with people locally and
overseas
to get better exposure and experience to
how to feature our
our cultural costume out of singapore
and one of the upcoming ones which we
are still in the midst of discussion
will be at the
aspara fashion week whereby it's going
to be um
their first time and my first time to
see how can we do a fashion show
uh on zoom platform and within a short
time period in a small screen and this
can be quite a challenge but it's a good
experience for us at the same time
yeah and to conclude the
whole thing
to allow our culture to
[Music]
perpetuate in years to come there's a
really a social need that we
try to make the costume um unique
to our consumers that there's a sense of
belonging and pride to wear them
and for culture to move on to the next
generation and
art and craft have to evolve
and in previous uh slides and
kirk have shown very good examples from
other countries
that people are starting to evolve and
create something relevant
to the young generation so we should
think about how can we reinvent
and make it appeal to the young people
and make it relevant to them
and of course there's one problem that
we face and that is
um cultural appropriation so
we i'll have to really calibrate you
back to the statement by carl sagan
that you to understand the past to
understand the present
with this statement in mind you'll be
able to appreciate the culture
but when you create something new you
won't create something that is kish
that may offend people and
people can't accuse you of not
respecting and culturally appropriating
their culture and i hope um this
presentation
would uh interest you in this part here
thank you very much yeah thank you mr
wong for the sharing on the evolution of
the narnia kobaya
and the proactive steps that have been
taken to ensure its relevance
interface of changing consumer
preferences and even environmental
trends such as
sustainability now i would like to hear
from the audience
on whose job do you think plays the
biggest role in safeguarding cultural
heritage
a poll should be appearing on your
screens now and the options are
traditional craftsmen and their families
and disciples
cultural and heritage communities
government agencies
consumers or even corporate companies
like your departmental stores or fashion
brands
whose role do you think can actually
help to raise awareness and the
preservation of these crowds
take a vote in the poll that has been
launched
okay i guess you can close the poll now
and you actually have quite a huge
spread of responses
a majority of you feel that the culture
and heritage communities are responsible
for safeguarding cultural heritage
followed by government agencies will
keep that in mind
consumers and then traditional craft
practitioners themselves
well actually there is no right or wrong
answers in this because in fact
everyone plays a huge and critical role
in preserving our crafts
so next step we will invite mrs tan
to come and share advice from about tao
kwon pottery jungle
and how they are worked with various
stakeholders to ensure that singapore's
last surviving dragon clean
well continues to survive mrs tan the
stage is yours
hey i'm nilantitan from the taokong
pottery jungle
as a second generation of running the
beast
family business okay i'm sure that most
of you didn't heard about what is a
dragon hill actually dragon kiln have a
long history about 3000 years ago
it is originally from china and this
dragon kiln
has been brought to singapore
in the earlier 30s by the immigrants
from china but mainly they are from tutu
and there are about 20 dragon kiln in
the past in singapore
okay this is the front part of the
dragon kiln
okay my father-in-law is a
fungi born to chill that came in
singapore
earlier and but she he started the
dragon kill and took over the business
in 1965
and we do the small cottage industry
producing the rubber cups rubber cup is
something like this
it's something like this is collecting
the rubber set
and most of the dragon kill in the past
producing this kind of the
rubber cups until about 70s that we have
producing the
orchid pots and in the 70s
after the 70s that we have producing the
local flavor
like the gift for
tourists
something like this and all the beef
from
most of the kiln in the past as a small
cottage
industry and due to the demands
after the 80s due to the demands
declined and most of the pieces of
ceramic was important so that we need to
have the competitions with the imported
ceramics
and we have to stop the production using
the dragon kiln
since late 80
then we were in 2001 after the stock
productions of the
ceramic is in the late 80s then we start
doing the important exports
until the 2001 we have awake the dragon
king again
but it is not used with production but
we use it for the hobbies
and for the interest groups to
try and experience the firing
because of this decline that we have no
choice that we have
moved forward to make this craft alive
we move forward to the education that is
we think that
it is more appropriate and through this
education
to share about the process of the
ceramics making then we're coming back
to
introduce heart is the traditions
and we also through the education
we also can share with the audience with
the community
the process of the ceramic and what's
the difference between the modern
him and the traditional craft and
through the exhibition
to the other event the outreach to the
community
then we also to share with them how to
appreciate
the craft the unique craft of it and
through the effect of it because for
most of the people that they think that
the craft of the traditional
ceramics is very rough like the orchid
pods
they do not understand the effect and
for most of them
they don't understand the process so
we are throwing the process to show them
the different way of forming it
and from this forming and also
to show them the process not just
digging the clay and they made
then it can be very modern from this
modern
then we can text on the young people to
participate on
to learn the process from from learning
the process
then they will we will share with them
about the dragon king
about the tradition so they can learn
from the exhibition they can learn also
the process
uh the effect of the this uh
unique effect of the dragon kiln because
some of the pieces
they're firing the dragon kill or fire
in the
electrical modern kiln are different so
from the pieces that fire in the
electrical kiln
is very constant and from firing from
the dragon
king or the traditional kiln there's
some unique pieces that you cannot
achieve
so that we have from there that in 2000
we start
forming artists together the hobbyist
and we gather the passionate people and
family
share how the dragon king works and
how the techniques of it and the using
of the clay
so that through there then to take their
interests
to this part of the traditional craft
okay next please
of course about six years ago we have
injected our
new blood means that our third
generation coming in
to help us and to promote and to make
this
traditional craft young
so we are hoping that to take on the
young generations
from through the workshop they have the
first-hand
experience on it and also we have
due to this coffee 19 then we also
having the our
online workshop on no online store so
that
we show them about the difference
of different kind of the ceramics
through there that we hopefully after
this pandemic they can have the first
hand
experience and coming back come back to
dragon kiln to try on their ceramics
from there because surrounding is
something different that
we can't do by the virtual hands-on
as they need to fill it with the
different kind of clay
but we also we plan we also do with the
our next plan we are also doing with our
virtual
tour so that they can understand that
how the dragon kill
work and how it tastes uh how
the whole dragon kills the inside the
dragon kill
and how the actually the dragon kill
works and
the process of packing it actually the
whole process
is about the labor of love through
experience
i think that they will not understand
how to sustain
and to safeguard this part of the
heritage
this is specking of the kill this is
inside the keel so every pieces of the
artwork you have to pack it
by hand manually and every time it's
the effect of it let me show you the
effect this is we keep the tradition
so that we don't lose this tradition we
keep
before the firing we need to do the
praying
ceremony and we will start from the
firing box
this is how it starts
then this is a side stock hole that uh
basically that
this is inside the kiln while they are
firing
as we are doing the firing these few
years
my group of the clinic artists
we do some research so that we can
more record that to passing down to more
people
more community that willing to learn and
to continue to keep
this dragon kiln fire
it's after the firing we have to unpack
and
find the dragon king is a teamwork so
you can't do it by yourself
that you have to have a big community to
experience
and to work together
this is the beauty of the different kind
of the effect from the wood fire
so this subject reductions firing means
that this effect you won't get the
second piece as the pieces actually it's
green color you can see
from the green green uh colors at the
side of the cup
then after the reduction the unique a
bit that they turn naturally
to pinky or to purple wish
next one this one is more modern that
people
to give them a another feel that
firing of the traditional art craft
it is not just the raw clay that you see
like an orchid pot
or the flower pot or you know but it is
you can
add in some color to enhance the beauty
of it
and all this beauty of it is by the
unique of it that you cannot get the
repeated
effect from them
this is more raw and more natural
because
this is uh something that uh
different from the periods that with the
color this one is a raw one without the
color
that we have applied with the different
clay means that
ceramic is not only uh that if the
shape or model it but you can experience
with different kind of the clay
then they will give you a different
effect of it that is the beauty of the
wood fire
same thing as this one we do not apply
any color
in fact that we have applied a very
little
and as you see from the side here you
see from
this part this is just a very
light color nature that's colors
from the wood ash but this is a raw
piece
raw clay color from different clay and
this is the draw clay
this is also raw clay this effect is
given
accidentally but from the flame of fire
means
that it comes from the flame of fire
that given
from the wood next one
and this one we have add some glaze that
to have
more young flavor that maybe you know
the more young flavor that to me can be
used for the
table you can seal not only the flower
pot you can
have some of like pieces like a
cup that you can have this is a card
that you know
that more people would like to use
actually the dragon kiln in the past
they are making as their livelihood as
their daily use item not only the flower
pot
but right now we also do some of the
plates this is the wood firing plates
that have different
effect this is also from the dragon king
far ring
and also you can do for the
this this one is also from the wood
farming
so that
and also another one this is a flower
for the the masses from the flower
arrangement
so it is very young
looks for them you see but it is not the
fight one
very vibrant color because the pieces
from the dragon campfire ring of
the wood tradition firing there's a
unique pieces
and it looks everlasting
i mean from my personal uh opinion uh
personal view of it
they are not like very vibrant
colors of it and this this is a piece
that
we we did it without any color
without any color applied and it is from
wood firing and this effect is from the
fire that is
from the wood there there's a flashing
it's the bottom of it you see through
this educational through this process
through this knowledge then we hope that
to get the young more young people
and a young generation and to sustain
also
our tradition and they can be accepted
easier to for them to accept it
this is more traditions this this
picture
is more tradition that is very raw and
natural
so it's quite difficult it's not
significant what i mean that
maybe some of them do not accept this
battery tradition that's why we have
given through these six years
we are doing a lot of research and try
to have
more different effect and
more variety that can show that we
fire in the dragon kill the effect what
is a unique effect from the dragon gem
okay so from if we we are sharing this
one
this part from that but we have to share
the process from the beginning from the
process
the education then how the process of
making
so they can understand the process
through this process
they can understand the whole uh
forming it is have to be step by step
through here then we will move them
forward to understand the traditional
craft
and the unique of it from the
appreciation of these
traditional craft that we hope that we
can have
passing down to young and young people
and also to passing down the this up of
the dragon king firing
to the next level and bring the
awareness of the
wood firing to the local community
of course that hopefully from the
virtual tour that we can
have the space for our tradition and
culture
to local and foreign
hopefully that we also can attract more
tourists to singapore
thank you thank you mrs tan for the
sharing i feel like i've just been
brought through a journey into tongues
dragon clean
now we are now moving into the q and a
segment and i would like to invite mr
yoke
and mr raymond wong to join us
so i do see some questions that are
coming in through the q and a module
so if any other thoughts from today's
sharing please feel free to keep your
questions coming
our first question comes from mabel and
he's actually directed at mr raymond
wong
asking if raymond if you might be
training any proteges when it comes to
passing on the kabaya making craft
across future generations okay
as i mentioned previously in my slides
kabaya is actually a slow fashion
and compile itself right we actually
have
two main groups of people just coming
together to produce one kerber
so the first group is the pattern
drafter because the goodbye
no matter how beautiful the embroideries
you can produce
if the cutting of the dress does not
accentuate the awareness beauty
then it defeats the purpose of doing so
much embroidery under clothes
so for my side i've trained um i'm
training my assistant
to be a patent drafter that that can
patent draft
based on our customers requirements of
how long how short and how fitting they
want their clothes to be
and this requires a lot of experience
because um you need to really appreciate
the women's freeform body
whether she's parachute body or very
hourglass body it requires
time experience to uh to do that
and this can cannot be learned from
school because usually in school they
actually use a mannequin to actually
teach that um that part
then the other one is the machine
embroidery portion
over the years i've trained a lot of
students doing cabaye embroideries
the aim is we hope one day these
students may want to perpetuate the
culture and do compilers but the thing
is
if they don't know kobaya then what
happened to the craft so we do hope that
with this
knowledge base they can actually try to
create their own
new creation that can be a new singapore
good design
not just in the form of kebaya and of
course for outside
um we are doing traditional cabinets i
try to train
with that knowledge that i have it
doesn't mean that i could do the
kobayash on my own
in other words i can also import from
workers
and train them how to do the buyers
which are more affordable for our
general public
so in other words the information itself
is very important
we need to know that know-how first
before we go on to do
any designs or managing the process
itself
yeah and that's my answer for this
question here thank you
thanks for the insightful response well
now we have a question from daniel and
he asked about
how or what does the national heritage
board consider as
cultural appropriation um would you like
to take this question
yes thank you uh daniel and i also see
another question
uh by johnny which is also talking about
cultural appropriation so i guess i'll
take
both questions together so i think
firstly to
daniel's question what is uh what we
consider as cultural appropriation
so i think at nhp we don't have a
definition but i think
by and large i think what people will i
think the
perception of cultural appropriation is
when one majority group
say a majority race borrows
a culture which is could be the culture
from the food
um dressing fashion
uh or craft and so-called
boros elements and uses it burrows from
the minority group and uses it
without the consent of the group or
individual and that creates the
perception that
it's problematic because it's seen as a
dominant group
you know taking from a smaller minority
group
uh and and there's a lot of emotional
response to some of these incidents and
i think
the incident that johnny mentioned about
the food and his
case is very true it created a
response emotional response from people
and
understandably so because culture is
something very
true and very deep we
entwined to our identity i i don't have
a
simple straightforward answer how do we
deal with it because the same case is
viewed very differently from
from the lens of different people uh so
there was one case
i will use a case from the american base
um since we're on topic of fashion right
so there was i remember reading a case
where a young
white american girl wore a chong song to
a prom
dinner and that triggered i think of
course
thinking about photos put on social
media and trick a lot of uh
negative response people especially from
asian americans were saying hey that's
my culture why are you wearing it
you know but then the same same sim
photos went to china
and a lot of people say you know it's
good it's like people actually
appreciate our
culture not just within us so the same
incident
because of your your own personal
environment can trigger very different
responses and i think the only way i
think i guess one way to
deal with it is how do you um treat
treat um you know with respect because
at one point we don't want it to be very
curious that oh this culture can only
stay within this
this this you know this group like the
kabaya i think is enjoyed by
people from different ethnic groups uh
singaporeans and non-singaporeans it
would be a shame if we
put this war around our culture and say
this is mine and
and don't touch it but we need to do so
respectfully
and you know listening and thinking
about you know how how would it how
would the minority group response often
i guess especially for for for majority
groups we
we might not think so much about some of
these issues but i think we take a step
back sometimes especially we are looking
at
cultural design all that we might need
to take a step back and see how do we
respectfully do a bit how do we perhaps
talk to someone
uh who was involved in the field or we
who
understands the culture before we embark
on some of these
efforts to try to change modernize adapt
designs and so on
so that's my take on the issue of
cultural
appropriation thank you thank you
yes indeed culture is something that is
very close to our hearts and perhaps
might require some careful navigation
so our next question is actually for mrs
tan
uh mrs tan um the question is about how
do you work with
or foresee working with modern
practitioners
like home-based potters or home-based
designers
this is time would you like to take this
question
yes i think so it's a good question
i think before um
i would see that uh for those potters
uh in experience for the wood firing or
the designer
i think it is the best way that they can
experience with
us uh on our farming so they can
experience the process
and also that they can experience the
material use
before they design something because uh
clay they have a lot different type of
the clay that you
it is not suitable for type a
but it is suitable for design on the
type b
so this is very important when they
design or the potters that
experience process because a lot of some
other partners they don't experience
on the wood flooring but the experience
on other part you see
so from there that we can share we have
no problem to share with them and
all to contribute to correlate with them
for that part you know
so i think it is the best that they can
come and experience with
us what is the firing so they can
understand the
effect of it and through uh corroborate
with them
they can contribute their design they
are forming
so whether it is suitable for wood fired
and different i am very concerned about
the
material that they use to
fire in the dragon gym because the
material the clay
that is used for the best effect what is
the best effect that can
use it for firing in the dragon chill
they will be different for
the modern kiln
okay right so our next question is
actually open to all three speakers
it's about what kind of design
collaborations do you actually hope to
see
arising from today's sharing is there a
sort of dream project that you would
like to embark on in
future that is perhaps
multi-disciplinary or cross-disciplinary
types of collaborations
um hi i think i'll start first
personally i feel that um there's a lot
of
design collaborations that can be
actually explored
um ever since the corporate exhibition
by nhb last year
it actually opened um a lot of people's
eyes including myself
that cultural culture can inspire people
and it can be beautiful and if you
understand the history well
and you recreate the culture into a new
form
it actually is wonderful that the
culture is really impressing
our culture is impressing other people
outside of our country
and this is the kind of collaboration i
think um young students needs to be
exposed
because they don't see the valuable um
ich of our collection in the museum
or in our culture itself yeah
for me i i don't have a dream project
i would say anything that you know if if
we can marry
some of the design one design with a
traditional crafts
i would it would be a dream come true it
doesn't i'm not looking at a specific
form
so i was wearing like i mentioned
sharing this i was actually very
inspired when
when during my holidays or past work
trips i had a chance to visit
other countries like korea and japan i
also saw
the civil servants there telling me you
know how they have tried to convert
and pair the designer so if we could do
something similar
with some of our local craftsmen that
would be uh
i think a good success for us thank you
i think it is good for corroborations
like you know
uh like what i agree with that you have
to
work together to come up with
it's not the design but it is the
experience of it
great thank you for your response our
next question is actually for
calcium and is asking if the national
heritage board is already working with
craftsmen to translate this craft a
contemporary audience
i guess it's a bit similar to the
previous question on collaborations yeah
i would say i think at the national
heritage board with a lot of our past
efforts have been trying to see how we
can offer a platform
for our traditional practitioners our
classroom
raise the awareness general awareness
level so we do
involve them in programming in for
example our annual
singapore heritage festival but i think
we honestly have not tried to do
something like
really focusing on design so i think
this is some one area that i think we're
trying to work
towards like i mentioned we started off
giving awards to try to recognize
individuals
i think this is another area i think
hopefully we will try to focus more on
attention
going forward yeah so that's my short
answer to this question thank you
thank you um we're coming near to the
end of the q a session so be taking two
more questions just to wrap things up
our next question comes from wendy so
wendy is asking whether
it was open to all so many is asking
whether you see any difference between
craft knowledge for
artistic expression or craft knowledge
for industrial production
i'll take this answer since since you
mentioned about japan i will give a
japanese example
several years ago i was in japan i i
happened to bump into
this very interesting shop selling
chopsticks so
then i noticed that the chopsticks cost
a few hundred
to a thousand over us dollars per pair
so i started looking at you know they
had a storyboard talking about the
history of the shop
so it used to be manufacturing
chopsticks in large quantities
but of course chopsticks manufacturing
is no longer
profitable to make by hand right because
it's like mass-produced
industrial uh disposable kind of wear
so what the shop actually did was to go
into creating more artisanal products
so like this so so they they talk about
you know how
how they create more literally paid
artwork on the chopsticks the lacquer
the quality
so those are still made by hand so i
think it has evolved from
uh the shop for example as well from
industrial production
but in order to survive and still
protect its artisanal traits it had to
evolve into
i think a more artisanal root so i won't
say they are mutually exclusive
but i will use a term like evolving like
this is living heritage so it evolves in
the times
and and and somebody probably in their
shop decided to innovate
reach out to a new audience in order to
stay alive and they have
um created that i think many examples in
singapore also i think maybe mrs stan
you want to share a bit also i mean you
were involved in
production of poetry right now also
looking at a lot of these artisanal
products
yes yes so i i knew first i think that
it's very clearly you know the current
knowledge of
artistic expressions of wood firing
or the knowledge of for the production
because
the pieces that for the production for
the industrial production
these pieces as the wood firing every
pieces is different there is a unique of
it
so it is not the productions means
you know i mean it is not the
productions uh
in the mass production type but uh
the people have to understand that
the pieces is the artistic
peace but there is a unique
is not the mass production there is a
difference in between these two
what i i want to express to them
so i can't say that because of
production mass production that
i can say expression is different but of
course like
making the plates but how far that uh
people that can appreciate that they are
using these
artistic plates than the mass production
plates right
understand okay so the last question for
this evening is actually a quick maybe a
quick sentence or response from all the
of
these speakers um the question is what
is the richest part of singapore's
culture
to you so what makes singapore's culture
so special in other words
for myself i think it's the
multiculturalism
and pranayakan culture itself is a very
good example of nanyang culture
that we have started to assimilate
various
interesting cultures from other races
and
repackage and give it a new look that
reflects our lifestyle over here
so personally i feel it is the
multiculturalism that
makes singapore culture very very unique
and interesting
yeah actually for me it's also
multiculturalism but maybe just to add
on and expand the discussion it's also
i hope there's a certain openness to
people
to to try to appreciate and value
the culture that is from the others as
well
that i think is what makes our
multiculturalism so special the respect
value that we are called to
others thank you
is this time would you like to add
anything yes i think
because singapore is multicultural
but i think a ceramics that you know
although that uh
it is that was brought in from the
immediate
from china but i think that the form
that used that
any uh any racist or anybody's that
can can can shape on their own
so become the become the unique of
their different cultural pieces that to
be fired
in the wood kill but uh
but more concern is about the effect but
a true
through the effect of the wood fire
the artistic effect then they add to
the value of different culture right
thank you thank you so much our
panelists for the engaging discussion
today
so i think it really gives us a quick
sense and we connect back to our roots
and also a deeper appreciation for our
cultural roots and what it means to be a
singaporean
to our attendees we hope that this
session has inspired you on a
preservation of local crafts
and even thoughts on how you can play a
part to safeguard our local culture and
heritage
now designers if you are inspired by
this sharing to research into new design
projects around cultural identity the
good design research initiative is for
you
in fact an open call will be launched in
october and we welcome your ideas on
design
impact driven projects i'm on this now
i'd like to invite my colleague maybach
to give
us a quick sharing on the open call and
some of our upcoming events
thanks jerica so for those of you who
are keen on
design impact projects and are seeking
for inspirations and suitable project
partners we hope that this series
of engagement and sharing sessions will
be meaningful for you
so in this slide you will see the
schedule for upcoming events on
designing for inclusivity
that leads up to our second open call in
october
if you would like to receive the latest
updates for these activities
please do share with us your email
address in our post event survey
and we hope to see some of your
submissions this october
so on more details of the open call um
for the support for the selected
projects we will actually be supporting
them with a cash sponsorship
up to for their projects up to the proof
of concept stage
as well as supporting them with
publicity and mentorship
and if you would like to submit a
proposal these are the three criteria
that we will be looking out for
in your submissions so first we are keen
to know your long-term plans for the
project
beyond the proof of concept stage the
intent is to ensure that our applicants
are committed to the project
and secondly we will be looking out for
submissions that explores deep research
that addresses global issues and which
goes beyond the standard user research
lastly we'll be also looking out for
projects that are clear
and how it strengthens the applicant's
unique value proposition
if you are keen to submit for the
upcoming open call
do express your interest also in the
post event survey and we will share your
and do share with us your email contact
to receive the latest updates
with this i'll pass the time back to
jericho
thank you hey me now attendees i hope
you have enjoyed today's webinar should
you
wish to revisit today's discussion a
summary of the keynotes will be shared
with you via email
along with the relevant links on how you
can reach out and find out more about
our various speakers
on the screen now will be two qr codes
um the leftmost one will be a quick post
event survey
and we'd like to hear more about your
feedback the post event survey can also
be found
in the zoom chat and if you like to find
out more programs
that the national design center has
lined up under the theme of singapore
our home
you can scan the qr code that's on the
right um please join me also in thanking
our speakers kurt xiang raymond and mrs
tan today for the wonderful sharing
and to all attendees we hope that you
have found the session
inspiring and meaningful we hope to see
you soon at the next
event and even your submissions under
the good design research open call
thank you